hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Gotham episode 10 video one more
episode left in the first half of the
season so let's go just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet as you can see like the biggest
thing in the episode I think is Bruce
Wayne going a little Batman just one
step closer to being the world's
greatest detective and just to start
with top 5 WTF Bruce vs. silver so we
finally get to see Bruce take her on and
we learned that he was deceiving her at
least a little bit this entire time this
episode he really laid it on thick when
they showed that creepy rape fan
checking them out I totally took the
bait who else thought the minute they
opened that van and silver was tied up
that you thought that she was the one
that hired them
it made the Bruce reveal at the end that
much more fun if you guys are familiar M
Malone the character that silver names
is matches Malone from the comics now
what they've done is they twist it
because Joe Chill is the person that
killed Batman's parents I'm not sure why
they're using matches Malone in this way
because matches Malone is the secret
name that Bruce Wayne uses when he wants
to infiltrate criminal organizations
like if you've ever seen Batman the
Animated Series there are a couple
episodes where he actually puts like
fake makeup on like he pretends to be
someone else to get information matches
Malone flows a lot from world's greatest
detective stuff and it is fun seeing
Bruce and Catwoman work together again
those two actors I feel like work best
when they're together on screen whether
you love or hate child actors I feel
like their scenes work best when they're
playing off of other child actors when
they're doing kids stuff on to my number
4 WTF Gordon and Bullock playdate in the
sewers so this is so fun seeing them
together again there's been a criminal
lack of Gordon Bullock scenes the first
half of the season I think we'll get
more of that now that book is back on
the force the whole deal with the first
part of the season was Bullock being
like I'm done with this I'm not gonna be
a cop anymore but I did laugh just a
little bit when Gordon went all Batman
voice to try and get information out of
the order he learned the order is trying
to kill the son of Gotham
but he doesn't know that Bruce is the
son of Gotham yet it gives you a good
idea for how the people in the city
think of Bruce right now when you read
stories about adult Bruce Wayne in his
own comic books the city thinks of him
as being a very big deal he's the most
powerful most influential character
inside Gotham City so of course
everybody that lives in the city thinks
of him as the son of Gotham the
double-edged sword is that Batman is
also the son of Gotham all the terrible
things in Gotham
together had a baby and that baby is
Batman on a my number three WTF
Theo's evil villain monologuing this is
actually kind of a funny thing for
anyone that's watched The Incredibles
because you know it's like the worst
thing ever for a villain to be cop
monologuing oh my god you caught me
monologuing this is a really important
scene but I feel like the way they set
it up was complete ham sandwich like the
best comic book moments on TV turned the
lesser moments into the ham sandwich you
know like like Barry Allen going on a
date being awkward that's complete ham
sandwich it's not really that important
of a moment when your big bat makes a
big reveal you really you don't want it
to be too awkward and I feel like this
Theo Gotham reveal was way too
deliberate but whatever we've learned a
couple important things Theo is a really
badass fighter and he has everyone on
their knees right now or at least he
thinks he does he had Gordon captive
until penguin rescued him and now he has
Bruce with his family's knife so he's
gonna exact his revenge on oh my number
two WTF the penguin in the Riddler
continued their strange relationship the
whole comedy of this situation was Lee
walking up and saying hey how's it going
you know what's what's going on with
Miss Kringle oh she's gone she took off
with her abuser never you mind that
ringing phone and actually the
interesting thing is is that he saved
miss kringles glasses despite the big
speech that he gave to penguin last week
this is a very Batman villain type of
thing
sabotaging your own evil plants because
of the little bit of human that's left
inside of you even though usually you
see villains exploiting heroes
weaknesses to get what they want Batman
does the exact same thing he will not
hesitate to exploit the humanity in
villains to take them down
the thing about villains this season on
Gotham though is that I think Theo
doesn't really have any humanity he has
his sister and I haven't really gotten a
family vibe from them it seems like
Tabitha cares more about Theo than Theo
cares about Tabitha speedy one of my
number one WTF moment Alfred vs tabby I
totally loved that he called her tabby
this is the best fight of the episode
this version of Alfred way better than
the movie versions of Alfred there's a
whole lot of things on Gotham this
season that I feel like are a lot better
than they were in season 1 the show
itself is getting a lot better season 2
season episode 2 episode but
consistently this version of Alfred has
always been awesome Shawn Pertwee's
Alfred one of the best
I know people got really upset when he
slapped Catwoman earlier this season but
this version of Alfred is hardcore this
is hardcore Alfred
he'll slap anybody he wants the bigger
question I saw people asking about
Tabitha though is whether or not
Catwoman is gonna get her whip at some
point because the whip is a big part of
the tab of the character so hopefully
we'll at least see Selena acknowledging
the whip as being really cool like oh
man I gotta try that at some time but
just in general something tells me that
Selena's progress towards becoming the
Catwoman character will mirror Bruce's
journey to becoming the Batman character
so they'll proceed it about the same
pace so don't expect one to get a
costume before the other but let me know
in the comments below what was your
favorite moment from the episode and
what do you think is gonna happen with
the order of st. Dumas after the
mid-season finale do you think they're
gonna push it into the back half of the
season because they still have their
Court of Alex storyline to surface they
can't really get through that till we do
order of st. Dumas stuff and they
haven't even brought Azrael onto the
show yet they did say younger version of
the character would appear at some point
but because the order of st. Dumas such
a big thing I mean it's like a League of
Assassins situation where I don't think
they'll ever completely go away forever
so they'll probably end up doing is
dealing with this blood of the nine
situation save Bruce Wayne and then the
order of st. Dumas will flow into a
quarter valve storyline because I think
this blood of the nine has to do with
the original ruling families of Gotham
although primarily their beef is with
the Wayne family but I do think Gotham
totally made the right move and giving
Bruce kind of this mystery arc about his
origins his family's origins like all we
come from this secret society that did
terrible things let's learn more about
this so regardless of any ham sandwiches
that you want to hold against the show I
feel like it's moving in the right
direction but just to give you guys an
update on what's going on this week the
schedule is a little bit different
because it's Thanksgiving week in the
United States so a couple shows are on
break there is a new episode of
Supergirl I'll do a video for that later
I also got some really cool stuff from
the Shannara people at MTV so I'll do a
video for that later this week too and
they're supposed to be Captain America
Civil War footage tonight so that ends
up happening I will totally do a video
for that next but that's not happen
until much much later tonight just in
case you guys haven't seen it so much
Game of Thrones and legends of tomorrow
stuff happened yesterday you can click
here for the full legends of tomorrow
trailer footage from the actual series
it's so badass
and you can click here to learn all
about the Jon Snow Game of Thrones
teaser the HBO posted thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you